today we go through everything you need
to know about joe biden from his
personal history to his political
history
from the senate to the vice presidency
from his corruption to his gaffes
everything i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't like the government spying on you
then visit expressvpn.com
to stay anonymous we'll get to
everything in the news plus
a full breakdown of everything you need
to know about joe biden
today is the episode that you're going
to send your friends who are thinking
about voting for joe biden just so they
have the
full information on exactly whom they
are voting for not just who they're
voting against i understand a lot of
people voting against trump but who they
are voting for we'll get to that in
just one moment first let's talk about
the fact that if you look at that bill
like every month you look at your
your bills every month one of the big
ticket items on your bill is probably
your cell phone bill and you think
yourself well that's something they
can't change i mean
after all i need my cell phone well yeah
you do and you need great coverage but
what if you could get that exact same
coverage for like half the price what if
you were spending
way too much money on that cell phone
bill and that repeating bill would not
have to impoverish you anymore i'm
talking about switching
to pure talk usa what if there are a
company that gave you that amazing deal
every day that's what you get with
puretalk a veteran run
wireless company think at t but much
better they understand what it means to
serve verizon at t t mobile if you're
with them you're overpaying pure and
simple
puretalk can easily save you over 400
bucks a year
listen this is all you need unlimited
talk text two gigs of data for just 20
bucks a month if you go over on data
usage they don't charge you for it
switching to peer talk it's the easiest
decision
you're gonna make today you can keep
your phone and your number or you can
get great deals on your latest iphone
or android okay the fact is that most
phone companies are intentionally
trying to charge you too much money by
telling you that you need unlimited data
you probably don't need unlimited data
what you need
is what pure talk is gonna give you
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
and again
if you go over on data usage they don't
charge you for it and it's going to cost
you 20 bucks a month grab your mobile
phone that'll pound
250 say ben shapiro when you do you save
off your first month so i'll pound 250
say keyword ben
shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless go join them right now
dialpound250
say keyword ben shapiro to get started
and save tons of money
on your wireless bill with puretalk usa
okay so
update on the polls we are now less than
one week away from the election
we are watching this race titan nearly
everywhere so we are seeing in the
senate for example
that in maine the sarah gideon susan
collins race has tightened it
dramatically
the latest polls there show that this
race is basically
nearly a dead heat there's a recent poll
that had them within at one point
if you look at the senate race in iowa
it now looks as though that is a margin
of error race between joni ernst
and greenfield who's the democrat over
there in georgia
it looks like the republicans are
probably going to take georgia it looks
as though south carolina is starting to
open up dramatically with lindsey graham
jumping
to a nearly 10-point lead in the latest
polls so the
the senate is very much up for grabs the
race in north carolina between tom
tillis and cal cunningham
is now within a margin of error with a
couple of late-breaking polls with
showing tillis up a little bit by a
couple of points but certainly this
thing is basically a dead heat
meanwhile in the presidential race the
national average
for joe biden has now dropped it was
close to 10 points just a couple of
weeks ago
it is now 7.1 points and there are
several polls showing this thing
narrowing pretty dramatically there's an
emerson pulse run biden up just five
and ibd tip people showing biden up just
four and a rasmussen poll showing biden
up just two
all of which came out in the last two
days so this race is tightening
dramatically because in the final
moments a lot of republicans are coming
home
and maybe some democrats are thinking to
themselves i'm not sure i love
this joe biden character if you look at
the battlegrounds things are tightening
dramatically in states across the board
florida
in the real clear politics poll average
is now trending trump trump is now up in
the real clear politics poll average
in florida as i predicted i think
florida is going to go for trump
georgia trump is up north carolina is a
dead heat
i mean literally a dead heat the real
clear politics poll average right now
puts biden at 48.7 and trump at 48.
arizona biden has just a two-point lead
in pennsylvania
it is just a 3.8 point lead for joe
biden there's an entire article in the
new york times today
about why it feels like donald trump may
in fact win pennsylvania again there's
an entire article in the new york times
by sean mccreesh
an editorial assistant for the opinion
section called can we trust
pennsylvania's polls they show joe biden
clinching crucial counties so why does
it feel so different
on the ground here and he has an entire
piece here talking about how
if you drive around rural pennsylvania
the fact is that this is trump landia
i mean that's literally how he describes
it his polls show mr biden leading by
five to 13 points
in pennsylvania but i grew up around
here and i'm dubious this place the land
of hoagies and bradley cooper and rocky
balboa worship and tina fey's cousin
karen accent
has transmogrified in trump into
trumplandia he has so much more support
than in 2016 because it's been four
years of accomplishment
said zarina thompson 49 a homemaker who
is talking with a group of women
outside a trump store they were part of
a caravan that had just encircled the
democrats rallied to say bye-bye to
biden and let his supporters know
they were outnumbered pollsters say that
suburban women
are president trump's kryptonite that
they've turned on him at another
pennsylvania rally the president pled
suburban
women will you please like me i feel
like that's wrong where the majority
said jennifer gerard 41 a single mother
working in consumer goods
who was standing near a pink dodge
challenger emblazoned with women for
trump
gerard said she was part of a group that
raised enough money to erect women for
front billboard over the stretch
of i-95 that crosses from the city into
the suburbs
a lot of these women are obviously big
trump fans but the fact remains
that there are a lot of trump supporters
in pennsylvania and things seem to be
dramatically narrowing in pennsylvania
even nate silver is pointing out that
this is not a
large biden lead nationally speaking he
may have a very solid lead but in the
swing states he does not
in pennsylvania things have really
closed up
in arizona florida georgia ohio those
are all states that trump
either will win or is on the verge of
winning and remember
joe biden he can win the popular vote by
a fairly significant margin he can still
lose the election
in fact according to a study from uh
that was headlined over newsweek last
week
if joe biden carried the popular vote by
four points donald trump has an 88
shot of winning the electoral college so
if this thing shrinks within four points
all of a sudden donald trump gets
re-elected this doesn't mean that donald
trump is uh is definitely favored at
this point
nothing like it it does mean that his
people look at the real possibility of
joe biden being president
not just that donald trump not being
president but joe biden being president
they are they're feeling a little more
skittish mitch mcconnell the senate
majority leader who released an ad
yesterday pointing out why it is the
democrats
really should not be allowed to lead the
country forward this is one of the best
ads of the campaign put out by the
senate majority pac here is
what it sounded like late nights
the early mornings the door knocking the
phone back
we put in the work we have the team
and the stakes couldn't be hired you're
considered the most
liberal united states senator
hi everything is on the line
now there's only one thing left to do
hold the line go vote that really is
going to be the republican line here is
that the threat of democrats is so bad
that they cannot be
let in charge of power and when you
watch what's happening in philadelphia
which is being
basically blacked out by the media i
mean i'm looking
at the front pages of various major
publications
and there's very very little coverage of
what's happening in philadelphia so
overnight
there were these massive riots in
philadelphia 1 000 people
looted the local walmart why well
because the cops
shot a black man who was charging at
them with a knife he had a knife they
told him to put it down he was then 10
feet they tried to back away
he refused to listen to their orders
they shot him this is now created two
straight nights
of brutal rioting across philadelphia
and those riots resulted in some pretty
shocking footage
okay the and listen to the headlines
from the media i mean this is this is
how you know
that the democrats are scared about
pennsylvania because they refuse to
cover this stuff they just refuse
here is how cnn headlined this protests
erupt for a second night after a black
man fatally shot by philadelphia police
missing a little bit of context as we
would say in the fact-checking business
aren't you it wasn't just that a black
man was shot by the police it was that a
black man was holding a knife
and they told him put down the knife
repeatedly and he approached them
repeatedly and then they shot him
but apparently that no longer matters
i love listen the top headline at cnn
right now
philadelphia sees more protests over
fatal police shooting here's what one of
those protests looked like
in philadelphia last night this doesn't
look like a protest this looks like a
full-scale riot with people looting
stealing a pair of shoes to uh to
protest systemic american racism because
nothing says systemic american racism
quite like the cops allowing people
to loot the walmart does this look like
a protest to you
right here what you're watching doesn't
look like a protest to me the prior
night 30 police officers were injured
including
a 56 year old female police officer who
was hit with a truck broke her leg
you can see cars are literally pulling
up to the walmart people are getting out
of the cars
they're running into the walmart and
they are just absconding with tvs
and and this is what democrats are
presiding over democrats are okay with
this
and they make noises about how they're
not super fond of it what exactly are
they doing to stop it
the mayor of philadelphia who's a
democrat said there were serious
questions to be asked about the incident
there were not
the police chief who's a democrat said
the same thing
okay this is the world that democrats
are apparently okay with because america
is systemically and institutionally
racist
thousands of people looting local stores
why would you ever invest in a business
in philadelphia again
watching this happen seriously well at
least the protesters the protesters here
some of them look like they're wearing
masks that's that's really the important
thing i noticed
okay so what exactly is the case against
trump when it comes down to it the case
against trump is just that trump is a
big bad orange man who's very bad in
orange
like the lincoln project what i think is
the single funniest dad i have ever seen
in my entire life yesterday
this ad sums up all of liberal feeling
it's a lincoln project
first of all just kudos i mean really
just
all sorts of props on being the greatest
grift i have ever seen it's an
incredible gift because the lincoln
project you will recall
was begun by a bunch of former
republican strategists
who couldn't make money in republican
politics anymore and decided they were
not just anti-trump they were anti-the
entire republican party that's how you
know it's a grift
it is one thing to say you don't like
trump and you don't want to see him in
the white house it is another thing to
say that susan collins needs to lose her
senate race
because you don't like donald trump but
that's what the lincoln project has done
so the lincoln project has raised tens
of millions of dollars tens of millions
of dollars
from democrats because democrats think
oh these are our converts these are
these are people
who who have decided to leave trump
behind and they're going to lead the
fight here
okay five seconds if donald trump is not
in office anymore the lincoln project
will be tossed on the side of the road
like a used condom they'll be done
right no one's gonna care about these
people no one's gonna like them no one's
gonna care about them
they'll go back to being you know tepid
republican racists
in five seconds flat but they are
cutting some pretty amusing ads
and paying themselves lots of money to
do so so here is an ad they cut against
trump this is their closing ad
against trump in the waning days of the
election
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a mother walking into her sleeping
child
hey honey
you asked me to wake you and tell you
what happened in the election
who won
trump trump won
but i thought you could only be
president two times
[Applause]
not anymore
oh stop it more it will never stop hold
about oh my god
that ad sorry
that's some funny bleep right there oh
it's the lincoln project pitch is that
if you don't stop trump now he's gonna
be president
forever forever
i just want to point out there's only
one president in american history who
served
uh more than two terms it was fdr
there's a democrat
that's when they uh that's when they
passed a constitutional amendment saying
that you could only serve
two terms not sure exactly how the
lincoln project thinks that trump
uh will continue to serve after two
terms but apparently that is the great
fear
they don't even have to make a case
against trump they're just that
that's some funny stuff right there well
it turns out that those scare tactics
may in fact not be working because it
turns out on the other side this is
something i've been pointing out for a
while
when you vote against donald trump
you're voting in favor of joe biden
i don't mean if you vote for a third
party or something or you just don't
vote i'm talking about if you vote for
joe biden you vote for joe biden
and it turns out that joe biden there
are a few themes to his career
and we're going to go through all of
them the first theme is that joe biden
has switched every position he has ever
held on a major issue
there are only a couple of exceptions to
that rule and they are in the far left
direction
the man moves with the wind he is not a
principled person
in any way shape or form okay that's
point number one number two
he's been engaged in low-level
corruption and sometimes somewhat
high-level corruption
his entire career not the kind of stuff
that violates the law but exactly the
kind of swampy behavior that you would
expect from a 47-year
politician who's been in congress since
he was
29 years old since he was elected at 29
years old
the third theme is that he's been wrong
on every single foreign policy issue he
has ever set eyes upon
every single one he's been wrong on all
of them
and so if there are themes to joe
biden's career it's that he moves with
the wind
he's wrong on everything foreign policy
related and that he is low level to a
high level corrupt
and then he's a gaff machine if there's
another theme right all these things are
well known about joe biden
but from to my mind it is the very first
thing that he shifts with the wind
that's what makes joe biden scary
because he's been campaigning as captain
returned to normalcy
he's been campaigning as i am a return
to all that is good and steady in
american life
remember one of the reasons that donald
trump was elected in the first place is
because the old normal was not very good
it turns out that the old normal which
was filled with corrupt politicians like
joe biden
joe biden and not only that
it was filled with politicians who are
going to basically follow the dictat
of the radical left and that's what's
going to happen this dude is not a
bulwark against the radical left he is
not a return to normalcy he's a gateway
drug to radicalism
we're going to get to more of this in
just one second we're going to run down
everything you need to know about joe
biden soup to nuts
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact
that if you are engaged in business if
you're a business person one of the
things that you may notice
is that your call volume has been going
down and one of the reasons your call
volume may have been going down
is because nobody likes to use the phone
that way what people like to do is text
i have not actually put a call into a
company for probably several years at
this point instead
i like to text people because it takes
less time i don't have to wait on the
phone or anything like that well what do
you need to do you need to convert a lot
of your business communications
to text and this is where podium comes
in
97 of text messages get open if you're a
business owner you're trying to market
to somebody
text messages get opened 90 are open
within
three minutes you need to be texting
your company your customers and they
need to be able to text you
if you're spending time on the phones
scheduling appointments you need podium
if you're sending invoices in the mail
you need podium if you need to convert
more sales from your website you need
podium
podium it's a business messaging tool
that gets you off the phone and into
texting
if you're not using texting to reach
your customers you are simply leaving
money
on the table podium brings all your
messages into one centralized inbox your
whole team can access
letting you save time while responding
to customers faster if you need more
reviews on google or facebook text it
if you need to send an invoice go ahead
and text it if you need to schedule an
appointment you just send a text
podium customers have seen some
fantastic results recently a plumbing
company converted 16
of their web traffic into leads a
national retailer collected 18 000
reviews
across its locations a property
management company increased revenue by
i mean whatever your business is texting
is going to help for a limited time sign
up for 20
off your plan they are so confident that
if podium does not make your business
better within 90 days they will send you
a 150
amazon gift card for the holidays go to
podium.com shapiro to get started that
is 20
off if you go to podiumpodium.com
shapiro again go to podium.com shapiro
today
to get 20 off and again they're so
confident that either it's going to work
within 90 days or they're going to send
you 150
amazon gift card for the holidays pretty
solid deal podium.com
shapiro to get started today okay so
let's go through
joe biden i know we haven't spent a lot
of time talking about you bite and
that's the way joe biden would prefer it
joe biden has spent this entire campaign
hiding in the basement and refusing to
ask simple questions like
would you like to pack the court he says
things like
i i i don't think i i need to answer
that question because
then you'd be talking about me and you
wouldn't be talking about donald trump
right that's the point that's the point
because people look full
full and face the joe biden candidacy
they see a couple things
they see joe biden and they see standing
right behind him grinning
kamala harris because they know that
with joe biden what you probably get is
a kamala harris administration but biden
himself is bad enough so
let's start with uh joe biden's life
story so joe biden was born in 1942
in scranton pennsylvania that's a long
time ago gang
okay like that is a very very very long
time ago he is
he is an elderly gentleman his family
moved to delaware when he was nine he
likes to talk about how he's from
scranton
okay he's from scranton in the same way
that i'm from burbank and i moved from
burbank when i was 11. he moved from
scranton when he was nine
okay he was a self-described poor
student in high school but he was
popular
his uh his crappy academic record uh
maintained throughout his academic
career
he went to university of delaware he was
ranked 506th in a class of 688. he went
to syracuse college of law he ranked
76th out of a class of 85.
again you can be not a great student you
can still be a good politician that's
quite possible you don't have to be
brilliant to be a good politician
promise as we'll see joe biden is
typical politician he received draft
deferments for vietnam while he was in
school
he won his first senate race in 1972 at
that time he was 29 years old
and then the the tragedy that has come
to define his personal life happened
that same year his wife and daughter
naomi were killed in an automobile
accident
and his sons were injured in that
automobile accident as well which
obviously under all circumstances is
just a horrific horrific
tragedy uh biden would later claim that
the person
who was involved in the accident on the
other side was drunk that turned out not
to be true they've asked for an apology
biden has not yet granted it
biden subsequently married jill biden in
he became ranking member of the senate
judiciary committee in 1981
he ran for president in 1987 he flamed
out amidst accusations of
exaggeration and lying and plagiarism
okay so what did he do
while he was in congress well he did an
awful number of things
first of all he was the father of
borking so borking is the practice that
has basically destroyed our supreme
court nomination
hearings right that practice is where a
uh is where a politician
decides that a well-qualified judicial
nominee cannot sit on the court because
you want certain results from them and
that person is unwilling to grant you
the results biden didn't treat him as a
serious judge
instead he suggested he was a stooge of
the reagan mis agenda
writes george neumeyer for the hill
which is correct
biden's treatment of bork was so bad the
washington post
wrote while claiming that judge burke
will have a full and fair hearing
senator biden this week has pledged to
civil rights groups that he will lead
the opposition to the confirmation as
the queen of hearts said to alice
sentence first verdict afterward
how can he possibly get a fair hearing
from biden who's already cast himself as
the role of prosecutor instead of juror
in the judiciary committee biden
suggested
that uh bork was bad why because bork
was an originalist and originalism was
bad right bork
said biden said to bork will we retreat
from our tradition of progress or will
we move forward continuing to expand and
envelop the rights of individuals in a
changing world
which is bound to have an impact upon
those individual sense of who they are
and what they can do biden suggested
that he was a
puritan who who wanted to break into the
bedroom
uh biden was was very happy about this
right and uh apparently he recalls
testing his portrayal of bork as an
enemy of privacy at a mall in delaware
he said people who knew me would walk up
and say hey joe and i'd ask them if they
thought married couples had the right to
use contraception
they'd look at me like i was crazy of
course and when i asked why none of them
said the right to privacy they all said
the constitution and therefore that's
the tactic that he used
on borg now he brags about this right
being the father of the destruction
of judicial nomination hearings is one
of his uh bragging points here was joe
biden in democratic debate just last
year bragging about this
i was part of the reason why elena kay
going to work for me got on the supreme
court
i was part of the reason why ruth bader
ginsburg is on the court i was part of
the reason why sort of my heirs on the
court and she swore me in
i presided and i'm the reason why this
right wasn't taken away a long time ago
because i
almost single-handedly made sure that
robert bork did not
get on the court because he did not
think there should be a numeric rights
okay i mean that is correct i mean the
man at least owns that
his time in the judiciary committee was
a disaster he also presided over the
clarence thomas and needed a hill
hearings
in which he scorelessly accused
without proper evidence clarence thomas
of engaging in a pattern of sexual
harassment
later justice thomas wrote that biden
told him he would begin with softball
questions instead threw a bean ball
straight at my head
he said senator biden's smooth and
sincere promises he would treat me
fairly
were nothing but talk now ironically
enough
biden has been forced to apologize to a
need to hill because
he was not harsh enough with clarence
thomas
the new york times later reported that
was april of this year
that uh he had to call up anita hill and
apologize
because he said he believed her but at
the same time he uh he didn't
try to brow beat thomas enough turning
it to hill's liking so of course
this is typical biden he then apologized
for everything that he had done to anita
hill
which is amazing amazing he what he
tried to do
was scurrilously destroy clarence thomas
without
proper evidence but he wouldn't
apologize to anita hill
afterward okay all of that the the boar
hearings at least will lead up to his
1988 campaign
he ran for president first in 1988 so
this idea that he's been promoting that
the reason he ran for president this
time around in 2020
which last i checked was three decades
after he first ran for president
he says that was about charlottesville
it wasn't the man's want to be president
since he was
in his late 30s early 40s right at the
very
latest he ran in 1988 it flamed out the
reason it ran out
it flamed out is because his
presidential campaign was a bleep show
it turns out that he was a liar it turns
out he was an exaggerator it turns out
that he was a purveyor of myth
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
if you are in credit card debt you need
to get out of it right now what you
don't need is to rack up those
additional
credit card bills because once you start
racking up the interest rates you are
done you are toast
instead why not consolidate all those
credit card bills into
a credit card consolidation loan from
lightstream rates start at 5.95
apr with autopay and excellent credit
the rate is fixed so it will never go up
over the life of the loan
plus there are no fees get a loan from 5
000 bucks to 100 000 bucks you can even
get your money as soon as the day you
apply
livestream believes that people with
good credit deserve a better loan
experience and that's exactly what they
deliver
people love lightstream and there's a
reason for it sometimes it saves your
financial
life there's a great opportunity to
solve your credit card debt problem
my listeners can save even more with an
additional interest rate discount the
only way to get the discount head on
over to lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m dot
com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.95
api to 19.99 apr and include 0.50 auto
pay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit
terms and conditions apply offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information okay so how
badly did that 1988 race go
horribly horribly according to matt
flegenheimer writing for the new york
times last year
biden's first run for president was a
calamity some missteps
still resonate joe biden was riffing
again an rfk anecdote a word about civil
wrongs a meandering joke about the
baseball commissioner and aides knew
enough to worry a little
when i marched in the civil rights
program i did not march with a 12-point
program biden thundered
testing his presidential message in
february 1987 before a new hampshire
audience i marched with tens of
thousands of others to change attitudes
and we changed attitudes
more than once advisors had gently
reminded biden of a problem with this
formulation he had not actually marched
during the civil rights movement
more than once biden assured him he
understood and kept telling the story
anyway
by that september his recklessness as a
candidate had caught up with him he was
accused of plagiarizing in campaign
speeches
he had inflated his academic record
reporters began calling out his
exaggerated
youth activism i've done some dumb
things biden conceded at a stop the
bleeding news conference at the capitol
i'll do dumb things again by the way he
was the frontrunner in 1987. in the
first quarter of 87 he raised more money
than any other democratic candidate
he vowed that day to fight on he quit
that race within a week
okay one of the reasons that he quit the
race is because he was accused
of plagiarizing he plagiarized his life
story from neil kinnick who was a
british politician
and then they uncovered the fact that he
had engaged in hijinks shall we say
while he was in college with regard to
using other people's material
he had flirted with the presidential run
in 1984
and then he came back in 1988
and he uh struggled to verbalize a
campaign rationale that felt true to him
words that felt absolutely authentic
but didn't matter uh the fact is that um
it just it just didn't work for him it
didn't end up working for him
in february of 1987 biden borrowed from
a robert kennedy speech without
attribution
he later said the remarks had been
written for him in april biden would
later recall a camera crew caught him
berating a new hampshire man who asked
about his academic history i probably
have a much higher iq than you do i
suspect biden shot bat before
exaggerating his record in school
the clip did not originally find wide at
circulation
uh typical biden right so this this is
who
joe biden was he was ambitious he was
always ambitious he was an exaggerator
he was a liar he was a typical
politician in other words
okay and joe biden has a long-standing
habit of putting his foot in his mouth
the fact that now the media are
declaring that joe biden has no problems
with putting his foot in his mouth you
know it's just the media making things
up
dude puts his foot in his mouth all the
time
all the time i mean back in 2008 time
magazine
put together an entire list of biden
gaffes
it was like the top 10 biden gaffes and
that is a very short list okay joe
biden's gaffes
go back decades for example
here is joe biden suggesting that barack
obama was the first mainstream
african-american who's articulate bright
clean
right you remember this one i know we're
all supposed to ignore the the subtle
racism here but here is joe biden being
subtly racist
i wouldn't go anywhere in confined
places now it's not that it's going to
mexico it's in a confined aircraft when
one person sneezes
it goes all the way through the aircraft
that's me if we do everything right
we do it with absolute certainty we
stand up there and we make really tough
decisions
there's still a 30 chance we're going to
get it wrong my memory is not as good as
justice roberts
it will not be six months before the
world yes
barack obama like watch we're going to
have an international crisis
generate a crisis against the medal of
this guy
hillary clinton is as qualified and more
qualified than i am
to be vice president on space america it
might have been a better pick than me
but she's
chuck graham state senators here chuck
stand up chuck come
see you chuck was a person in a
wheelchair god love you what am i
talking about
you got the first sort of
mainstream african-american yeah
who is articulate and bright and and
clean and a nice looking guy you cannot
go
to a 7-eleven or a dunkin donuts
unless you have a slight indian accent
but this standard is not a measure of
how we can evaluate the condition of our
society
it cannot measure the health of our
children the quality of our education
the joy of their play this is how it
sounded when robert kennedy said those
words in 1968
yet the growth national product does not
allow for the health of our children
the quality of their education for the
joy of their play
okay so bottom line here joe biden is a
career long dishonest politician that is
not a shock he also happens to be a
vicious politician ranging from borg to
clarence thomas
to mitt romney you'll all recall when he
said in 2012 that mitt romney is going
to re-enslave black americans
that was good times he's going to let
the big banks once again write their own
rules
unchain wall street
they're going to put you all back in
chains he's going to put you all back in
chains yeah that's
that's good old joe biden nice guy right
nice nice good good
guy now speaking of uh joe biden's
corruption
so this has become a big issue in the
campaign so theme number one is that joe
biden is a typical
lying politician he's been doing it for
years we'll get to his positional shift
in just a second
his corruption has been a long a long
known story okay there is nothing new
about this take for example august 2008
cbs news reports that mbna paid joe
biden's son
as biden back to bill a son of
democratic vice presidential candidate
joe biden was paid
an undisclosed amount of money as a
consultant by mbna the largest employer
in delaware that was biden's home state
during the years the senator supported
legislation that was promoted by the
credit card industry and opposed by
consumer groups
barack obama's presidential campaign
said biden helped forge a bipartisan
compromise on the issue which is now law
and makes it harder for consumers to
obtain bankruptcy protection in the
courts
mbna's consulting payments to hunter
biden first reported by the new york
times followed his departure
in 2001 from the company where he had
been an executive
obama opposed the bankruptcy law enacted
in 2005 biden supported it
at the time hunter biden was receiving
consulting payments from mbna
he was also a washington lobbyist at a
firm he had co-founded
he was not a lobbyist for mbna his work
had absolutely nothing to do with the
bankruptcy bill
zero nothing said one of his partners
david wade a spokesman for well actually
not one of his partners dave wade a
spokesman for the obama campaign
consumer and civil rights groups and
unions as well as democratic opponents
had argued that the bankruptcy
legislation was unfair to low-income
working people single mothers minorities
in the elderly and would remove a safety
net for those who have lost their jobs
or face amounting medical bills
the financial services industry made the
case bankruptcy frequently is a refuge
for gamblers
impulsive shoppers divorced or separated
fathers avoiding child support
multi-millionaires who buy mansions in
states with liberal exemptions to
shelter assets from creditors
when the senate judiciary committee
approved the bill early in 2005
biden dianne feinstein of california and
her coal of wisconsin were the only
democrats to vote with the republican
majority
mbna employees have poured more than 200
thousand dollars into biden's senate
campaigns
over the past two decades making donors
working for the credit card company the
senator's largest source
of campaign money good times good time
so
he is uh he took a bunch of donations
from mbna he then promoted a bill
that was to their benefit and uh nbna
treated them real nice they treated
sunrail mice they poured a bunch of
money into hunter's pocket this is going
all the way back to 2008 when it was not
considered verboten
to report on joe biden's corruption
meanwhile at the same time as michelle
malkin once reported
for national review joe biden was
involved in some sweetheart real estate
deals with folks over at mbna
according to malkin circa 2010 former
senior senator from delaware and current
vice president joe biden has a
custom-built house
in delaware's ritziest chateau country
neighborhood it is now worth at least
2.5 million dollars and is the biden's
most valuable asset
biden taps campaign funds to pay for his
compound's law needs he secured the new
estate with the help of a corporate
executive who worked for biden's top
campaign donor
credit card giant mbna in 1996 biden
sold his previous mansion to mbna chair
vice chairman john cochran
the asking price was 1.2 million dollars
cochran forked over the full sum
biden then paid 350 grand in cash for
real estate developer keith stoltz for a
4.2 acre lakefront lot stoltz had paid
that same amount five years earlier
for the undeveloped property stoltz told
the wilmington news journal the
residential real estate market was soft
at the time he sold the land of biden
soft for whom stoltz didn't need to sell
the property
reporter byron york looked at comparable
properties in biden's neighborhood and
found three cases
three cases where homes went for below
asking price
however nobody actually bothered to
negotiate
it appears that mbna indirectly helped
cochrane buy the biden house through six
figure executive compensation funds
listed as moving expenses and losses
suffered on the sale of his previous
home again this is just all inside the
beltway
garbage corrupt politics and as we all
know for a long time now
biden's family's been cashing in on his
career for decades ryan grimm writing
for the intercept which is not a
right-wing source
he says the problem for democrats is
that a review of hunter biden's career
clearly shows that he along with joe
biden's brother james
has been trading on their family name
for decades cashing in on the
implication and sometimes the explicit
argument that giving money to a member
of joe biden's family
wins the favor of joe biden democrats
have been loathed to give any
credibility to wild groundings of trump
or rudy giuliani leaving them to
sidestep the question of hunter biden's
ethics or decision-making
and how much responsibility joe biden
deserves investigative reporters and gop
operatives have dived deep into the
question
of whether joe biden ever used his
official power to do favors for special
interests
shoveling money to his family they found
no exact proof of this
but that doesn't mean the biden's
behavior isn't a legitimate problem for
democrats indeed
biden has been taking political hits
over the intersection of his family's
financial dealings
and his own political career for some
four decades if he has done nothing
publicly to inoculate himself from the
charge his career is corruptly enriching
his family
and now that is a serious liability
hey in 2006 bo biden who died of cancer
in 2015 was roped into an investment
meeting led by james and hunter biden at
the firm paradigm global advisors
the family was considering acquiring the
firm james biden told executives
he'd have no problem bringing in people
looking for an in with joe biden who was
u.s senator at the time
we've got people all over the world who
want to invest in joe biden james biden
told officials with the firm
beau biden turned red in the face he
told his uncle this can never leave this
room if you ever say it again i'll have
nothing to do with this
hunter and james denied the account to
politico the magazine stood by it
we've got investors lined up and we've
got investors lined up in a line of 747s
filled with cash ready to invest in this
company a paradigm executive recalls
james biden saying in 2014
a stepson of the former secretary of
state john kerry chris heinz gave hunter
a similar warning that pair were
partners in an investment firm rose
monsenica when hunter biden and a third
partner devon archer were invited to
were invited to join the board of
burisma heinz told the washington post
he strongly objected to hunter biden and
archer taking the board seats
obama administration officials were
concerned as well
in april 2014 of course hunter went
ahead and accepted the invitation to
join the board
along with a fee of at least fifty
thousand dollars a month
okay and then when later asked about it
hunter explicitly said
oh yeah by the way i mean of course that
had to do with the biden name
hunter was following the footsteps of
james biden says intercept
that's joe's younger brother it began
small in 1973 one year after joe was
elected to the senate
james biden opened a nightclub seasons
change with what politico
referencing contemporaneous local
reporting in delaware called unusually
generous bank loans
when james ran into trouble joe as the
senator later complained the bank
shouldn't have loaned james the money
what i'd like to know biden said is how
the guy in charge of loans let it get
this far
the paper investigated sources at the
bank said the loan was made because
james was joe's brother
james in the 90s founded lion hall group
which lobbied for mississippi trial wars
and lawyers involved
in tobacco litigation according to
curtis wilkie's book the fall of the
house of zeus the trial lawyers wanted
james biden's help
pushing joe biden on tobacco legislation
that same decade in 1996 hunter biden
got in the game he started working with
mbna
biden in the 90s was known half jokingly
as the senator from mbna though he
didn't find it
though he didn't find it funny he was
however mbna's greatest champion in the
senate
as we have discussed okay so the fact is
that
for a long time members of the biden
family have been cashing in on biden's
name and biden has done nothing about it
as we'll see this is starting to bear
some fruit in the
story of uh tony babalinsky we'll get to
that in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that you never want to visit an auto
parts store you really don't i mean it's
just not something you're interested in
doing
why should you wait in line these days
to get to the front of the line have to
answer a bunch of very specific
questions you don't know the answers to
they order you a generic part online
and then you have to put in yourself
anyway why not just go directly online
skip the middleman
and cut the cost this is why
rockauto.com is excellent
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear like airlines do
why spend up to twice as much on the
same parts rockauto.com it's a family
business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com they're always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts
the rockauto.com catalog it's unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate and
quickly see all the parts available for
your vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
you've got amazing selection reliably
low prices all the parts your car will
ever need
rockauto.com there's no make some money
you spend
tons of money when like why would you do
that makes no sense don't spend tons of
money when you can be spending less
money by using the interwebs at
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box
so they know that we sent you alrighty
so
all of this has now culminated in all
the talk about joe biden
and uh these chinese emails well the new
york post
now reports on tony bobolinski michael
goodwin reporting
that hunter's business partner has now
told all
with regard to joe biden he says for
tony boblinski the meetings with joe
biden are unforgettable
not because they had anything to do with
politics it's because that's when
bobolinsky fully understood joe was very
much involved
in the foreign business schemes that sun
hunter and joe's brother jim had cooked
up
the final proof came during two
conversations over two days in may 2017.
he first met the former vp in the lobby
of the beverly hilton hotel where joe
was to speak the next day at the milken
conference on the moonshot project of
finding a cure for cancer
babalinski told goodwin in a tuesday
interview hunter and jim and i are there
hunter gets up and talks to his father
when he comes in
he then brings joe over and introduces
me saying he's the one who's helping us
with the business we're doing
with the chinese if joe biden was honest
with the public when he said he never
discussed hunter's business with him
the next words out of his mouth would
have been what business with the chinese
what are you talking about but that's
not what he said according to bobolinsky
joe biden did not look surprised or
curious after a getting to know you
conversation
bobolinsky remembers joe saying my son
and my brother trust you em emphatically
so i trust you
good luck and work hard joe liked him
hunter and jim later said which
bobolinsky took
as an official seal of approval the next
morning after the speech bobolinsky says
he was ushered backstage to greet joe
biden again then walked him to his car
he recalls the former veep's parting
remark as keep an eye on my son and my
brother and look out for my family
babalinski appeared with tucker carlson
last night he said
look joe biden is lying he knows all
about his family's businesses here's bob
linski who is in fact a credible witness
with some receipts to back it up the
former vice president has said he had no
knowledge whatsoever of his son's
business dealings and was not involved
in them
at all but this sounds like direct
involvement in them yeah that's a
blatant lie when he states that that is
a blatant lie
obviously the world's aware that i
attended the debate last thursday
and in that debate he made a specific
statement
around questions around this from the
president
and uh i'll be honest with you i uh
almost stood up and screamed liar
and walked out because i was shocked
okay well you know he's saying that the
media are not reporting it
obviously because the media must protect
the pressures who is joe biden
but there's a long pattern decades-long
pattern of people in joe biden's family
taking advantage of joe biden's name
obviously joe biden had to know
something about this sort of stuff it's
been dogging him his entire career
whether he was implicitly involved or
making profit from it is another
question
but certainly he was looking the other
way which is deeply corrupt stuff i mean
he's a member of government it's not
you know trump doing business with his
kids before he was a member of the
government
that's just the family business okay
being in politics the vice president of
the united states or a senator and
knowing that your family is
jet-setting around raising money off
your name and doing nothing to stop it
that is corruption it may not be
criminal but it is definitely corruption
at one point according to bobolinsky he
asked if the family wasn't concerned
that joe would run for president in
2020.
i said jim how are you guys doing this
it seems crazy he looks at me and kind
of chuckles and says
plausible deniability so
they're relying on that plausible
deniability meanwhile the feds have
obtained a fisa warrant against hunter
biden's chinese business associate
according to
documents chuck ross investigative
reporter for the daily caller says
federal investigators obtained
a foreign intelligence surveillance act
warrant against one of one of hunter
biden's chinese business associates
suggesting the executive was suspected
of acting as a covert agent of a foreign
government
prosecutors revealed the existence of at
least one fisa warrant against
chai ping patrick ho known as patricko
in a february 8 2018 court filing
obtained by the daily caller news
foundation
ho was charged on december 18 2017 with
conspiracy to violate the foreign
corrupt practices act
and money laundering related to cefc
china energy contracts in uganda and
chad
joe had been executive at cefc hunter
biden was part of a business consortium
that sought a partnership with cefc in
may of 2017.
a senate report released last month said
an affiliate of cefc wired 5 million
bucks to biden's law firm
from august 2017 through august 2018
apparently hunter biden also represented
ho
during his legal battle ho of course
apparently it was a fisa warrant because
they thought that essentially
he was a representative of the chinese
government who had not registered as
such
biden agreed to represent ho and find
out about the extent of the
investigation according
to the new yorker the new york new york
times reported in december 2018
whose first call following his arrest
the year before was to james biden
the brother of the former vice president
the senate report also said a shell
company affiliated with cefc
called hudson west hudson west 3 wired a
million bucks to biden's law firm
owasko on march 2nd 2018.
the senate republicans who released the
report said biden's relationship with
cefc posed counterintelligence concerns
because of yi's connections to the
people's liberation army and the chinese
communist party and the feds knew about
all of this apparently
so again lots of corruption inside the
biden family and the chance that biden
knew nothing about it
very very very very very low bordering
on the infinitesimal
and yet biden maintains that well
bobolinsky has fully said that this is
not true
okay but none of this even touches the
real reason that biden shouldn't be
present
okay there are lots of corrupt members
of congress there are lots of corrupt
senators there are lots of corrupt
people
who use their power in order to benefit
family members there are lots of gaff
machines out there in american politics
there are lots of people who have
exaggerated and told lies on the
campaign
trail right the real reason that joe
biden should not be president is twofold
one he has been wrong on every major
foreign policy issue of his entire
career
and two when it comes to domestic policy
he has shifted every single position
he has ever held except for a couple of
core ones namely he
he freaking hates guns right that is a
big one is that he's be he's back to
anti-gun measures his entire career
print any and he likes higher taxes
those are pretty much the only
consistence in his entire career
he blows with the wind the lie the
greatest lie of this campaign
the greatest lie of the campaign is that
joe biden is going to be a bulwark
against radicalism he is not
joe biden follows where the wind blows
that is his entire career that is what
he is
he is proto-typical follow the follow
the leader politician
he has never taken a leadership position
on anything of importance he has never
been in a in a position where he is the
guy who's ahead of the crowd
he is constantly putting his finger in
the air and then following
where that leads okay and right now the
prevailing winds in the democratic party
are to the far left we'll get to
more of this in just one second because
we will prove this time and time out
wrong on foreign policy
and has no principles on domestic policy
first let us talk about protecting
those eyeballs so you're spending an
awful lot of time in front of screens
these days
right even if you normally work in an
office where you're not working in front
of screens well now you're probably
working at home so that means that you
are working in front of screens or
you're watching tv
you're on your phone you're on your cell
phone well you know what that blue light
can do it can wreck your sleep quality
it can give you a headache it can give
you eye strain
this is why you need a felix grays felix
gray blue light glasses
these are excellent excellent blue light
glasses there are a lot of blue light
glasses on the market they're not all
created equal
many blue light glasses don't filter
enough blue light especially in the
range that matters
well felix gray filters out 90 of blue
light in the most damaging range and
eliminates 99 percent of glare
through a proprietary industry-leading
lens technology only available with
felix gray
you can order online glass is shipped
directly to you with hard case and lens
cloth included you try them for 30 days
risk-free if you don't like them ship
them back if your screens aren't easier
on the eyes send them back for a full
refund
go to felixsgrayglasses.com for the
absolute best quality blue light
filtering glasses on the market that's
felix grayglasses.com
f-e-l-i-x-g-r-a-y glasses dot com slash
ben
shipping and returns are totally free at
felix gray felix grayglasses.com go
check them out right now okay we're
gonna get to more of joe biden we're
actually gonna get to his policies
and what his career has been like and
we're gonna get to his actual
full-scale agenda for beyond the
election
in just one second which should scare
the living hell out of you for sure
we're gonna get to all of that
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that this has been an
insane year and that we are watching
right now the riots in the streets in
philadelphia at root this is about a
philosophical conflict between people
who believe that the country ought to be
torn down to the root and people who do
not
between unionists and disintegrationists
there's a philosophy out there that
believes that america is endemically
evil
that america was rooted in in racism and
white supremacy
there's a philosophy that says that your
basic american rights are in fact
discriminatory and bad
and then there's a philosophy of
american freedom i talk about all of
this in my book how to destroy america
in three easy steps i've been asked many
many times what is the single best book
that
an easy book that i can get for myself
for my kids to really understand
what's going on in the country to
understand the constitution to
understand the declaration of
independence to understand why these
principles are important this is that
book
how to destroy america in three easy
steps go pick up a copy today it's going
to be relevant for the election and
beyond
for sure you're going to want to cut
you're going to want a copy again buy
buy for all of your your
all the high school kids you know buy a
copy it's important stuff how to destroy
america
in three easy steps also you may have
noticed the presidential election is
almost here
we have an amazing day of programming
for you our live stream starts tuesday
november
3rd 3 p.m eastern 12 p.m pacific
featuring special guests live interviews
and more
leading up to a very special episode of
backstage where we will be covering the
results with you in
real time so we're going to be there
like all night even better join daily
wear right now get 25
off with code election so you can watch
all of our election coverage live
on our apple tv or roku app members get
our articles ad free access to all of
our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show exclusive readers past content
available only to daily wear members if
you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions you also get not
one but
two leftist years tumblers with your
membership as well as early sometimes
exclusive access to new daily wire
products so
watch the election with us at
dailywire.com get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you
sign up today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so theme number one when it comes
to joe biden's actual policies we have a
couple of themes with joe biden
one is that he is a lifelong career
politician which means all the
corruption
all of the gaffes all the exaggeration
all the lying all that is endemic to joe
biden's career then we get to his actual
policies
the biggest problem for him he's been
wrong on every major foreign policy
issue his entire life like
indubitably wrong and not just according
to wild-eyed right-wingers like me
right not just according to hawkish
people like me obama's defense secretary
robert gates famously said
that joe biden has been wrong on every
single foreign policy issue ever
okay here is uh here's robert gates
explaining just that
you said in your memoir joe biden is
impossible
not to like quote he's a man of
integrity
incapable of hiding what he really
thinks and one of those rare people you
know you could turn to for help in a
personal crisis
still i think he's been wrong on nearly
every
major foreign policy and national
security issue over the past
four decades would he be an effective
commander-in-chief
i i don't know i don't know i
i think i stand by that statement
so that is a harsh burn from the former
defense secretary for barack obama
right he served in the same
administration as joe biden he's like
yeah he's been wrong on pretty much
everything
and uh that happens to be accurate he
has been wrong on pretty much everything
so
our story begins with the gulf war of
1991 joe biden voted against it
that was one of the most successfully
prosecuted wars in american history joe
biden was against it
fast forward a decade now joe biden is
very much in support
of the war in iraq right he specifically
says
he says there's a lot of us who voted
for giving the president the authority
to take saddam hussein down if he didn't
disarm
there are those who believe at the end
of the day even though it wasn't handled
all that well we still
have to take him down right he says we
have one single focus that is we're
about to send our women and men to war
the president is the commander-in-chief
we voted to give him the authority to
wage that war we should step back and be
supportive okay i don't think he's
actually wrong
about that the problem is he then
flip-flopped on all of it right so in
biden then said that colin powell made a
compelling case for war
right he said he was asked did secretary
of state
powell today close the deal in your mind
to those who have an open mind about
iraq and biden said absolutely he made a
compelling case
the predominance of the evidence the
pure weight of the evidence i think
anyone let me put it this way
if i were back practicing law i can't
imagine i could not convince an
open-minded jury of the facts that he
presented
as having been true okay this is again
revisionist the revisionist history of
the democrats is that they were all
anti-war they they were not they were
all pro-war at a time when george w bush
was pro-war
there's no one who believed that bush
lied in order to get us into war
now of course that is the entire
democratic party line and many in the
republican party line
okay by 2005 biden had flipped just like
the rest of the democratic party
and suddenly the war was real bad
suddenly biden was saying that the iraq
war was a mistake as of 2005.
right he said in 2005 quote it was a
mistake
it was a mistake to assume the president
would use the authority we gave him
properly
i brought along that whole quote i knew
you'd ask me this i said we know he
continues to attempt to gain access to
additional capability
including nuclear capability there's a
real debate on how far off it is whether
it's a matter of years or it's a matter
of less than that we don't know enough
now that was the rest of my quote
i never argued there was an imminent
threat i gave the president the
authority to unite the world to isolate
saddam
we went too soon we went without
sufficient force we went without a plan
okay i just read you his quotes back to
back
no he was not resistant to the war in
2003. he was very much pro the war in
by 2005 like the rest of the democratic
party he had flipped
okay and then fast forward to 2019 and
now biden is just openly lying about
this stuff
right he fast-forwarded 15 years and i
was just lying he says you know
the moment that the bomb started
dropping i was against the iraq war okay
that's just bull crap it's not true it's
clearly not true
here is joe biden i did make a bad
judgment trusting
the president saying he was only doing
this to get inspectors
in and get the un to agree to put
inspectors in from the moment
shock and awe started from that moment i
was opposed to the effort and i was
outspoken as much as anyone at all in
the congress administration
nope nope nope nope nope
not true false okay then in 2006
joe biden opposed the iraq war surge
you'll remember this is the only thing
that brought
the situation in iraq under control
during the insurgency
because again joe biden has never been
right about a single foreign policy
issue
so uh he opposed the iraq war search
said i totally oppose the surging of
additional american troops into baghdad
it's contrary to the overwhelming body
of informed opinion both inside and
outside the administration
which is code for i don't like it but i
have no good excuse so i will cite
informed opinion
okay then in 2010 when barack obama
precipitously pulled troops out of iraq
you'll recall leading to the ride of ice
the rise of isis
joe biden declared it a major victory he
said iraq would be a great obama
achievement
the rise of isis began immediately with
the withdrawal of troops from iraq under
the obama biden administration heroes
biden being wrong again about iraq so
he's wrong every way you could be wrong
about iraq he's been wrong from every
single angle you could be wrong about it
he's been wrong
i am very optimistic about uh
about iraq i think it's going to be one
of the great achievements of this
administration you're going to see
90 000 american troops come marching
home by the
end of the summer you're going to see a
stable government
in iraq that is actually moving toward a
representative government yeah rongo
rongo it wasn't just iraq
on afghanistan biden opposed obama's
afghanistan surge which was done halfway
of course
he said that uh rather than focus on
nation-building and population
protection
instead you should do more to disrupt
the taliban improve the quality of
training of afghan forces and expand
reconciliation efforts
to peel off some taliban fighters okay
this is what drove robert gates to
suggest that biden was wrong
about every single thing david petraeus
also opposed joe biden on this
then in 2011 biden says he opposed the
bin laden raid right he now admits that
he opposed the bin laden raid
and that it was uh that was barack obama
who by the way that would make
biden like the only human being in
planet earth's history who has opposed a
raid to kill
bin laden like to me that is the most
obvious it's the most obvious call in
the history of american foreign policy
and joe biden opposed it
i said we owe the man a direct answer mr
president my suggestion is don't go
we have to do two more things to see if
he's there
okay so he didn't want him to do it okay
but it's not just afghanistan it's libya
so after the libyan invasion biden then
suggested that it was great it was much
better than iraq because nato got it
right
in this case america spent two billion
dollars and didn't lose a single life
this is more the prescription for how to
deal with the world as we go forward
than it has been in the past he was very
much in favor
of the nato war in libya which of course
ended with the complete destruction
of any sort of control in libya which
culminated in the murder of an american
ambassador and three other americans in
benghazi
in 2012 joe biden mocked the idea of
russia
as an adversary this is in the middle of
the 2012 election
when the uh when the romney campaign was
asked
romney was asked during a debate who is
america's greatest geopolitical threat
and romney said russia i know of all
member memory hold this time
when it was the democrats were very very
pro-russia but here's what joe biden
said at the time
governor romney's answer i thought was
incredibly revealing he acts like he
thinks the cold war is still on
russia is still our major adversary i
don't know where he's been i mean we
have disagreements with russia but
they're united with us on iran
the only way we're getting one of two
the only way we're getting one of only
two ways we're getting material into
afghanistan is through russia
they're working closely with us they've
just said to europe if there's an oil
shutdown in any way in the gulf they'll
reconsidering
they'll they'll consider increasing oil
supply syrup this isn't 1956.
this is in the midst of joe biden and
barack obama handing control of syria
over to the russians
allowing the russians in the short
months thereafter to invade crimea
okay so wrong on russia okay then wrong
on iran as well as we'll see
okay so the foreign policy wrongness for
joe biden they'd
just never stop he was wrong on iraq
every which way he could be wrong first
he was for the war
then he says he was against the war when
he wasn't really against the war then
later he says that he was against the
war from the beginning basically which
is not true
then he opposed the iraq war surge and
then he was in favor of precipitously
pulling out the troops
in afghanistan he opposed the obama
afghanistan surge
and then he opposed the bin laden raid
in libya he says that we did the right
thing in libya
he said that russia was not our
adversary they were our friend in 2012.
now of course russia
is the great bugaboo living under your
bed who's perverting every election on
behalf of donald trump
but i'm old enough to remember when joe
biden and barack obama were offering
flexibility to the russians while
presenting crimea and syria to the
russians on a platter
joe biden has been wrong on iran in 2015
joe biden was one of the chief
cheerleaders for the garbage iran deal
that gave iran a path to a nuclear bomb
as well as a bevy of cash in return for
literally nothing literally nothing just
iran saying oh we won't develop anything
for a few years
here is joe biden pushing the iran deal
which turns out to be a pile of garbage
i've come to the conclusion that in the
context i've just
cited that this is a good deal
this is a good deal for the first and
foremost for the united states
it's a good deal for the world the
region and it's a good deal for israel
and uh the gulf cooperation states
it was not even close to a good deal and
as soon as america pulled out of the
iran deal in fact
iran's economy started to implode and an
alliance in the middle east arose
against iran
directly as a result of the obama biden
willingness to cater to iran so he's
wrong on iran
not only is he wrong on iran just this
year you'll remember that joe biden
took the bizarre step of opposing the
killing of kasem soleimani
suleimani was of course the head of the
terror arm of the iranian gov
government he said no american will
mourn kassem soleimani's passing
trump killed him right he deserved to be
brought to justice for his crimes
against
american troops he supported terror and
sold chaos
none of this negates the fact this is a
hugely escalatory move
in an already dangerous region the
administration's statement says its goal
is to deter future attacks by iran this
action will almost certainly have the
opposite effect
president trump just tossed a stick of
dynamite into a tinderbox he owes the
american people an explanation of the
strategy and plan to keep safe our
troops in embassy
iran will surely respond we could be on
the brink of a major conflict across the
middle east were we on the brink of a
major conflict across the middle
east no of course because joe biden said
it which means he was wrong because he's
been wrong on everything
japan has never been right on a thing on
china joe biden said last year that
china is not competition for the united
states and it's foolhardy to claim that
china is competition to us
even at the same time that they are
promoting intellectual property theft
and all sorts of other goodies here's
joe biden circa 2019 saying china is not
competition for the united states
china is going to eat our lunch
come on they can't even figure out
how to deal with the the the fact that
they have
this great division between the china
sea
and the mountains in the east i mean in
the west they can't figure out how
they're going to deal with the
corruption that exists within the system
i mean i you know they're not bad folks
folks but guess what
they're not a cut they're not
competition for us
they're not competition for us guys
china's not competition for us okay so
he's wrong about that one too
and also he's just wrong about israel so
in 2020 after the
after the trump administration correctly
and morally finally fulfilled the
congressional promise to move the u.s
embassy
in israel from tel aviv to jerusalem
biden then says that while he's not
going to move the embassy back
he would never have moved the us embassy
to jerusalem okay this is all part and
parcel
of the bullcrap democratic arguments and
the foreign policy establishment
argument that by treating israel
honestly and decently
as opposed to uneven par with terrorists
like the palestinian authority islamic
jihad
that you have increased the the measure
of risk in the region all of that was
untrue here's joe biden being wrong
about moving the embassy to jerusalem
this is an administration that as you
know uh advocated
uh moving uh the capital of israel
to jerusalem from tel aviv if you are
elected president
would you reverse that not now i
wouldn't reverse it i wouldn't have done
it in the first place
he wouldn't have done it in the first
place guys what what what a genius
nothing amazing amazing because he's
been wrong on that too
because it turns out moving the embassy
to jerusalem not only did not result
in higher risk in the region after that
happened after the recognition of the
golan heights
after the recognition that the
settlements are not prima facie illegal
there were peace deals between israel
and half the arab countries in the
middle east
okay so he's been wrong on that too so
joe biden's history on foreign policy is
wrongness
from beginning to end soup to nuts he's
been wrong on every foreign policy issue
of his entire
life and like you want to make that guy
president
okay now we get to his domestic policies
so the theme of joe biden's domestic
policy is he says whatever will
move him forward at any point in time
there are only a couple of issues where
he's been consistent they are few and
far between
he has shifted on virtually every major
issue of his career
the most obvious is on crime and drugs
so in 1982
according to the intercept biden
actually told ronald reagan that he
wanted to ramp up
drug enforcement according to the
intercept in september 1982
biden gave a nationally broadcast
democratic response to the president's
weekly radio address
he accused reagan of quote unnecessary
budget cuts to crime funding
violent crime is his real threat to our
national security as any foreign threat
he said
will have a military budget of 253
billion dollars in 1983
and yet in 18 in in 1983 will spend less
than 3 billion
a year to fight crime he then called on
the federal government to support state
and local police agencies by training
their people
and giving them more money now that
sounds that's like music to the ears for
people on the right like me and this was
his theme right he was in favor of the
war on drugs he was in favor
of higher levels of anti-crime
enforcement here was joe biden in 1982
supporting the war on drugs
i think the president has to join us in
making a significantly greater
commitment to these six areas to stem
the rising tide of violence in america
and that's what it is violence
first we have to join together to ensure
the drug dealers are punished
swiftly surely and severely in line with
what the president is calling for
we have to hold every drug user
accountable
because if there were no no drug users
there would be no appetite for drugs
there'd be no market for them
okay that was actually in 1989. then in
1993 biden famously supported the crime
bill that poured all sorts of federal
resources
into ensuring that people got locked up
for their crimes again
this is all stuff that is a conservative
i'm like okay all right but here's the
thing about joe biden
whatever position he takes today will
not be the position that he takes
tomorrow this guy is no bullwork against
the radical left
nothing like that he is wherever he
thinks the crowd is and if the crowd is
on his left
that is where he will run if he thinks
that he requires the radical left in
order to win election that is where he
will run
he didn't require them to be bernie
sanders because there are still more
moderates than radicals in the
democratic party but
he needs the coalition of moderates and
radicals in the democratic party
in order to defeat the republicans so he
ain't going to be a bulwark for
moderation okay here is joe biden
circa 1993 talking up the crime bill
the underlying bill which is now the
biden hatch bill was the biden bill
a guy named biden wrote that bill and he
wrote that bill by going down and
sitting down with the president of the
united states of america
you must take back the streets and you
take back the streets
buy more cops more prisons more
physical protection for the people okay
so that's where he was right that was
his entire perspective
then in 2010 biden reiterated that he
was in favor of criminalization of
marijuana he said i still believe it's a
gateway drug
i spent a lot of my life as chairman of
the judiciary committee dealing with
this it would be a mistake to legalize
he said i think legalization is a
mistake as late as 2016 biden was still
defending his 1994 crime bill
so here is biden in 2016 defending the
crime bill another thing about how
uh perspectives change over time bobby
rush
member of congress said the other day
i'm ashamed that i voted for the 94
crime bill
you ashamed of that bill not at all um
in fact i drafted the bill as you
remember i know that
okay but then in 2019 this is a
beautiful thing about biden the man's
constantly evolving
he's constantly evolving you see he can
trust that whatever positions he says
he holds that are moderate they'll be
gone within a couple of years in 2019
biden overtly apologized for the crime
bill and in 2019
he had this to say he said i haven't
always been right i know we haven't
always gotten things right but i've
always tried
it was a big mistake when it was made we
thought we were told by experts that
crack you never go back and the two are
somehow fundamentally different it's not
different it's trapped an entire
generation okay in 2019 biden flipped on
the death penalty uh amazing
as his party moved left he randomly
shifted to the left i mean who could
have
but i thought he was a politician of
principal who will provide a damn and a
bulwark against the radicalism of his
own party
uh no no you're telling me that this guy
is a corrupt old bureaucrat
who is simply going to follow the
prevailing winds in his no no
here is joe biden suddenly flipping on
the death penalty which he'd been in
favor of his entire career
we should make sure that if in fact
someone is
put on trial for a crime that could end
up with a major sentence their life
imprisonment because it was a
capital offense and by the way
congratulations to you all ending to
death
[Applause]
okay then in 2020 she suddenly came out
against the uh the enforcement of
criminal penalties against marijuana
and he says nobody should be in jail for
smoking marijuana
asked by cnn if the former vice
president supports legalizing marijuana
andrew bates biden campaign spokesman
said biden believes the drug should be
decriminalized oh well
isn't that a switch in position well i
mean weird weird okay so that's all on
crime
right he's shifted his position from
tough on crime to lucian crime
and he's done all of it because that's
where his party has moved he will do
whatever is convenient to the moment
the most obvious example isn't even on
crime where he took his signal
accomplishment in the united states
senate on crime his signal bipartisan
accomplishment
and just chucked it directly out the
window as soon as it became inconvenient
on abortion he's had his own evolution
in 1973
biden actually supported getting rid of
roe vs wade in 1974
biden said of roe vs wade that
quote-unquote went too far
he didn't quote think a woman has the
sole right to say what should happen
to her body okay even as late as 2019
biden was reiterating his support for
the hyde amendment the height amendment
bans federal funding
for abortions so joe biden said in a
statement to abc news quote
his campaign said he has not at this
point changed his position on the hyde
amendment the hyde amendment does not
prevent organizations in the u.s that
provide life-saving health care services
for women from receiving the federal
funding they need by giving the current
draconian attempts to limit access to
abortion
if avenues for women to access their
protected rights under roe versus weight
or closed he would be open
to repeal the next year joe biden came
out and then openly denounced the hyde
amendment
right amazing so it's just incredible he
denounced the height amendment as of
june
2019 as recently as a couple days before
he had said he supported the height
amendment and then he just turned it
around and now the height amendment's
bad
i can't justify leaving millions of
women without access to the care they
need
and the ability to const to exercise
their constitutionally
protected right if i believe health care
is
right as i do i can no longer support an
amendment
that makes that right dependent on
someone's zip code
oh wow look at that he just flipped who
could have predicted such a thing
and then there was joe biden same year
saying that he would codify rowan law so
he moved from 1974 rose a bad decision
to 2020 row needs to be codified in
federal law
i mean it's almost as though the man has
no principles almost here he is
considering the new supreme court
nomination of amy
um coney barrett what are your
particular plans to protect women's
reproductive rights in the u.s
number one we don't know exactly what
she will do although expectation is that
she may very well move the overview
overview
over rural row and but the only thing
the only
responsible response to that would be to
pass legislation
making roe the law of the land that's
what i would do
okay so there is an abortion moving from
somewhat pro-life to completely insanely
all the way
pro-abortion pretty amazing pretty
amazing okay
then on guns there are only a couple
areas where he's been consistent guns is
one of them
so joe biden has been saying for years
that he uh that he is pro-gun he is not
in fact pro-gun all the way back in 1993
he supported an assault weapons ban that
is not a shock he has continued to
maintain support for an assault weapons
ban and then he says
occasionally idiotic things like i own a
couple of shotguns and if ever
somebody's at your door bothering you
you should fire a shotgun through the
door which is literally the stupidest
most criminal thing that you can do
uh also he says that cops should shoot
to wounds so he knows less about guns
than he knows about anything else which
is saying an awful lot he's been
consistent on guns i'll give him credit
for that he's been anti-guns
pretty much his entire career on civil
liberties he's not really spoken out
about uh the patriot act other than to
say repeatedly that he was one of the
original creators of the patriot act he
actually says that most of the
provisions of the patriot act created in
that most of those provisions were
actually first brought about
by joe biden in 1994 here was joe biden
saying that he supported the patriot act
during his 2008 failed presidential run
senator biden go ahead and respond
because you voted for the patriots you
know
let's facts are a funny thing they get
in the way
you know what i mean there is nothing in
the patriot act that allows profiling
let's get that straight nothing in the
patriarch allows profiling
okay so that was him backing the patriot
act so we'll see where he is on um
surveillance when if and when he becomes
president okay on immigration
this is a guy who went from being
somewhat in favor of having a border to
completely not
in favor of having a border in 2006. joe
biden supported the secure offense act
which was designed of course to build
fencing along wait for it waiver at the
southern border
i voted for offense i voted like unlike
most democrats and some of you won't
like it i bought it for 700
miles seconds but let me tell you
we can go to things 40 stories high
unless it changes the dynamics
in mexico and and
you will not like this and punish
american employers who knowingly
violate the law when in fact they hire
illegals okay so he sort of sounds like
a republican there right i mean he
wanted to build 700 miles offense and we
have to punish employers who hire
illegal immigrants by 2020 biden was
saying that he would make dak a
permanent on the very first day
the very first day he said this during
the debate the other night
he said as president i'll immediately
work to make it permanent by sending a
bill to congress
on day one of my administration i said
now he's totally in favor of open
borders pretty much
so shift again joe biden has no
principles none
okay gay marriage is supposed to be the
issue where he shifted the most
right he the gay marriage is the one
where where joe biden was the real
leader he was in the vanguard
okay what really happened is the obama
administration decided circa 2012 was
going to shift on this particular issue
they sent out joe biden to issue a trial
balloon do you really think
that joe biden was sitting in the
background thinking you know what i'm
going to leap out front here joe biden
has never been out front on an issue in
his entire life without the backing of
his party
without believing that the momentum was
behind him in 1993
joe biden voted for a bill deeming
homosexuality incompatible with military
life that was the don't ask don't tell
bill
in 1996 joe biden voted for the defense
of marriage act
right which was designed between shrine
traditional marriage
in 2012 of course he shifted and he said
that he was now pushing at same-sex
marriage and he just didn't understand
why anybody would oppose
same-sex marriage because of course he
was basically thrown out there by the
obama administration as a trial balloon
in the middle of the campaign
you're comfortable with same-sex
marriage now i i look
i am vice president united states of
america um the president
sets the policy i am absolutely
comfortable
with the fact that men marrying men
women marrying women and heterosexual
men and women
are entitled to the same exact rights
all the civil rights all the civil
liberties
and quite frankly i don't see much of a
distinction uh beyond that
massive trial balloon right and he they
throw that out there and then he becomes
obviously the great and good leader on
same-sex marriage
sure or alternatively the guy is
shifting on every position
and he follows the prevailing political
winds again on civil rights
in the 1970s joe biden opposed mandatory
busing of course
right in 1974 freshman senator joe biden
found himself under siege from white
suburbanites at a meeting just south of
wilmington in delaware that's according
to politico
the possibility their children would be
bussed into black schools in the city
and black children
would be bused to their schools had
since a wave of consternation through
the white community for two hours biden
paced the auditorium stage
and absorbed the ire of the 250 member
audience unable to offer them any
assurance on the court ruling he made a
promise to oppose bussing when he
returned to washington for the next
legislative session
and he did this of course became the
basis for the famous kamala harris
suggestion that he would have prevented
a little girl like her
from attending an integrated public
school
okay so obviously he has tried to disown
all of that
and then of course in 1996 joe biden
voted for welfare reform now he won't
even answer where he is
on welfare reform but this is joe biden
circa 96
if we really want welfare reform and not
a political issue
we must do it in a bipartisan way in
each of his compromise
and do it in the form the president can
sign this amendment
fits that bill it's the only bipartisan
welfare reform bill to be introduced in
congress
it's a bill the president said he would
sign and it's a bill that's gotten wide
editorial endorsement
and a bill that makes compromises by
definition of being bipartisan on both
sides
now his campaign refuses to answer where
he is on welfare reform because of
course
to answer that question means that he
might actually be held accountable for
his own policies according to nbc news
nearly 25 years after biden voted for it
in the senate his campaign declined to
say directly whether he stands by his
vote
so yeah there's a shocker there's a
shocker okay so why does this matter
because when you look at the actual
radical agenda that is on joe biden's
website
when you actually look at what joe biden
would like to do for the country it is
all radicalism he made an agreement with
bernie sanders bernie is out there
bragging that biden is going to be the
most progressive president since fdr
because he allowed bernie to fill in a
lot of the policy details on his
campaign website
now there are a lot of people out there
saying well joe biden he's a typical
politician so he's not going to do all
that
okay but what if the pressure is coming
from his left which it absolutely is
joe biden may think that he's going to
be able to find some sort of common
ground middle
with the republican party but what
happens when his own party rebels
against that
and he is forced into a coalition with
the most extreme elements of his base
the fact that joe biden has no
principles is the reason you should fear
that he is not going to be a bulwark
against the radicals in his own party
bill clinton had no principles either
and so when his political fortunes
started to shift beneath him
he started to cut deals with republicans
do you think that joe biden is going to
do that do you think he has the ability
to do that he doesn't have enough
democrats in his own party who are
willing to cut deals with republicans in
order to do that he's going to continue
shifting the way that he shifted under
barack obama to the radical left
so here is what is in joe biden's
radical agenda here's what's in joe
biden's radical agenda
let's take a look okay so his tax plan
according to the tax foundation
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden would enact a number of policies
that would raise taxes on individuals
with income above 400 grand
including raising individual income
capital gains and payroll taxes
biden would also raise taxes on
corporations by raising the corporate
income tax rate and imposing
a corporate minimum book tax biden's
plan would raise tax revenue by 3.3
trillion dollars over the next decade
there's only one problem is we'll see
when it gets to spending he's going to
spend way more than that
according to the tax foundation's
general equilibrium model the biden tax
plan would reduce
gdp by 1.62 over the long term on a
conventional basis the biden tax plan by
2030 would lead to about 7.7 percent
less after-tax income for the top 1
percent
about a 1.9 percent decline in after-tax
income for all taxpayers
on average it will lead to a loss of
over half a million jobs
in the united states according to the
tax foundation that is his tax plan his
massive
incredible tax plan how about his agenda
how much it's going to cost
so he's supposed to raise three trillion
dollars with this tax plan
there's only one problem the manhattan
institute's brian reizel
a former budget staffer used third-party
cost estimates of biden's proposal to
show that they cost more than 11
trillion dollars over 10 years
so he's supposed to raise taxes by 3.3
trillion dollars over the next 10 years
and raise spending by at least 11
trillion over the next 10 years
removing the three trillion dollar cost
of the house democrats heroes act which
is the
new covered relief program that they are
pushing they still would have to
increase federal spending by more than 8
trillion
over the next decade that will always be
an underestimate there is never a time
where they've estimated government
spending that it is coming low
analysts from the penn wharton budget
model a project associated with wharton
school
estimate that it would that even at the
lower end it would cost 5.4 trillion
dollars
over the next decade this means that
biden's plans would make federal
spending roughly 24
of gross domestic product by 2030 his
push for a public option which would
dramatically undermine
your private health insurance plan by
essentially having a subsidized
public taxpayer-funded system that
forces people
into the public system that's what
happens through a public option everyone
understands that's first step toward
getting rid
of private insurance joe biden on
education he's going to pour money into
the labor unions and he's going to
go out and he's going to wreck charter
schools his position on charter schools
is absolutely clear
according to the biden sanders unity
task force recommendations
charter schools should basically be done
democrats believe education is a public
good
and should not be settled with a private
profit motive which is why we will ban
for-profit private charter businesses
from receiving any federal funding
also they oppose private school vouchers
and other policies that divert
taxpayer-funded resources
away from the public school systems
you're going to see more money poured
into the labor unions and our crappy
public schools no more charter schools
federally funded
and we are going to remove the
possibility of school vouchers
joe biden is extraordinarily radical
when it comes to labor
he has been pandering to unions public
sector unions particularly
for a very very long time according to
steve delhi an opinion contributor for
the hill
his plan includes abolishing right to
work laws right these are laws that
state
that you do not have to be a union
member in order to work
in the public sector biden's plan would
return to the days where union members
or not employees would be forced to pay
at least some portion of their union
dues
or be terminated tens of millions of
workers would lose freedom from such a
policy
currently no federal law addresses
collective bargaining for state and
local government employees the issue is
left to each state biden would eliminate
that by making collective bargaining
mandatory for all state and local
government employees
they would eliminate the secret ballot
instead they would have card check
card check forces employees to vote for
a union by signing an authorization card
which means you can be bullied
into joining a union by the union higher
ups they'll destroy the gig economy
biden supports the nationwide adoption
of the abc test for independent
contractors
making it nearly impossible for workers
to be classified as independent
contractors so it'd kill uber it would
kill lyft
it would pervert it would kill the gig
economy and of course
he wants to radically increase the
minimum wage
on guns biden says that he's going to
put beto o'rourke in charge of guns
right he he literally said that he said
i want to make something clear
i'm going to guarantee you this is not
the last you've seen a beto you're going
to take care of the gun problem with me
you're going to be the one
who leads this effort so
joe biden is going to get radical on
guns obviously
he said weapons of war have no place in
our communities we need to ban assault
weapons and high-capacity magazines of
course
assault weapons is an ill-defined
nondescript term meaning whatever
democrats
want it to be biden is also going to
target religious freedom
his own website suggests that religious
freedom is uh to be subsumed beneath the
rubric of lgbtq rights
according to the biden website plan
religious freedom is a fundamental
american value
but states have inappropriately used
broad exemptions to allow businesses
medical providers social service
agencies state and local government
officials and others
to discriminate against lgbtq plus
people
so there should be no exemptions for
religious people
basically if you're a religious person
who operates a business all exemptions
go away you are now forced to do the
bidding of the state
on lgbtq issues so
i hope you've enjoyed your freedom of
religion it is going to be wildly
quashed under a biden administration and
again it will all get more radical
and of course biden is pushing a pathway
to citizenship for 11 million
illegal immigrants which i think will be
his very very first step
here is joe biden in the last debate
with president trump
i've made it very clear within 100 days
i'm going to send to the united states
congress
a pathway to citizenship for over 11
million undocumented people
and all of those so-called dreamers
those daca kids they're going to be
immediately certified again to be able
to stay
in this country and put on a path to
citizenship okay this is putting aside
all of the various other institutional
heresies that biden is going to preside
over
will he pack the court we don't know is
he going to stand in favor of getting
rid of the senate filibuster
maybe is he in favor of adding states to
the union
who knows okay joe biden will go
wherever the party leads that is his
record
joe biden is not the leader he's the
follower when he says things like this
is the joe biden party
sure sure it is okay so there you have
it soup to nuts that is the joe biden
story
if that does not give you pause about
voting for joe biden then go ahead and
vote for him
but just just recognize that if you are
talking about joe biden
voting against donald trump you're
talking about voting for that guy that i
just described wrong on every foreign
policy issue of his entire career
a serial exaggerator a career liar uh a
plagiarist
a low-level corrupted dude maybe he's a
nice guy seems like a nice guy
that's pretty much the only quality uh
that that seems
presidential in him is that he is a nice
guy so if that's enough for you to make
this this guy
president this nice guy president who
immediately will start implementing the
most radical
agenda of the democrats from the green
new deal and regulatory
expansions to the the prosecution of
people
on campus who are accused of sexual
assault without any right to do process
if you're
if you're in favor of all that by all
means joe biden is your guy if not
think twice okay well today to conclude
our extraordinarily long show
uh i had the opportunity to sit down
with our friends over at birch gold once
in a while we sit down with our friends
over at birch gold and give you a
financial projection on what's going to
happen
over the coming months i had a
conversation
with one of their precious metal
specialists here's what that sounded
like
well joining us on the line is philip
patrick precious metal specialist for
birch gold group as you know i've been a
big fan of birch gold for a long time
they've been long-time sponsors of the
ben shapiro show wanted to talk to
philip
about what exactly is uh going to happen
next given the state
of our really extraordinary politics
philip thanks so much for joining the
show i appreciate it thanks for having
me
so why don't we start with the election
the election uh is uh to happen
shortly what effect do you think the
election is going to have on stocks as
well as the overall economy
i mean as always i think a fairly
dramatic
effect obviously it depends on the
outcome of the election
uh if the polls are correct which
obviously we've grown to
to doubt in recent years uh they're
suggesting a biden win
if that happens i think it has a
dramatic effect on the market
what we can count on as we understand
taxes going up
uh three trillion dollars predicted in
excess taxes over the next 10 years
the concern is raises in capital gains
taxes could lead
investors to flee the markets in
anticipation
goldman sachs recently came out and said
a biden win could result in a 12
cut in corporate profits in the s
p largely on the back of of of these tax
raises
at the end of the day i think we know
what it amounts to and that is
larger government more spending and
ultimately
a move away from a laissez-faire and
free market economy it doesn't bode well
so philip if if trump is re-elected if
he bucks the polls and he is re-elected
what about then would the outlook be
better for stocks
look i think does it put us on a better
trajectory
it certainly feels that way um the one
thing we can say is
as good as he is in some respects what
he is not is a magician
right what he cannot do is make debt
disappear
or change the cyclical nature of the
markets the markets have been cyclical
since inception regardless of president
good or bad republican or democrat
the point being we've got tough times to
go through no matter who gets into
office
but certainly i think it would be a
better trajectory
so we've blown out the spending since
covet i mean to the tune of trillions
and trillions of dollars obviously we
can expect that that's going to have
some
impact on the on the efficacy of the
dollar going forward either tax are
going to have to radically rise or we're
going to have to start inflating the
currency
at some point in the future what does
that mean for precious metals investment
look at the end of the day it's climates
like that
that you speak of currency devaluation
inflation
these things act as drivers for precious
metals so
as bad as these things are for the
nation for us
for gold and silver they're they're
quite good at the end of the day it's a
very conducive climate for them
well on the other hand uh obviously
stocks this massive drop
in late february early march uh there's
this enormous
plunge and now they've recovered to
record highs i mean the stock market has
has done well
ever since then it has climbed back
obviously people are are optimistic
uh why shouldn't people be too
optimistic going forward about the
market
look for me it was the nature of the
rebound that was so concerning
right you know as you point out we had a
dow at all-time highs in january come
march we saw
essentially a 40 slide you know
what happened to turn it around did gdp
increase did unemployment drop
significantly no it was driven by the
fed the fed stepped in
six trillion dollars of stimulus our
debt
at the start of the year 22 trillion it
had taken
a long time to amass it today we're
approaching 27 trillion
it looks to be a stimulus-driven rebound
and the craziest thing of all
is what you mentioned people applauding
the concept look at that the strength of
the market
it's concerning and and more of the same
so when we look at precious metals going
into 2021 what is the outlook for
precious metals in 2021 obviously it's
been a wild year financially
yes indeed and just in general quite
frankly
look it it certainly bodes well and it
ties into
again what what you mentioned previously
we're moving into a climate that looks
very conducive
right if we were to ask u.s citizens
what are the major issues facing the
economy today i think most people would
mention
bubbles in the market debt inflation
currency devaluation
as we mentioned a moment ago these
things are all drivers
for gold and silver so the climate looks
conducive
on top of that i think options today are
more limited than they've been in the
past the stock market looks to have
problems interest rates are so low
creating issues for bonds or cash
limited options i think further support
the precious metals market
and in reference to that look at bank of
america's prediction they came out a
couple of months ago
they feel by 2021 gold will be at 3 000
an ounce so it seems to speak to
what we're talking about so if somebody
does want to diversify at least a little
bit and move some of their money into
precious metals
what would be the best way for for them
to go about doing that with birch gold
first thing to do is give us a call it's
what we do
we can help our customers roll over if
you have a retirement account you want
to put a portion of that into precious
metals
we have a structure in place that allows
you to roll over any portion
and place physical tangible metals tax
deferred within a retirement account
we can also assist with cash purchases
as well but i think the first step for
your listeners
give us a call get our information
should it make sense
we're here to facilitate obviously
volatile times breed uncertainty and
uncertainty is a good time to diversify
make sure that you are not
too much in one area or another with
your finances make sure that you are
invested at least a little bit into
precious metals the way i am with my
friends over
at birch gold all right philip so i know
that you are not uh
in the predictions of business more than
in general terms
um but you know you've already said that
you think that precious metals are gonna
be a good bet for the uh for the near
future
uh where do you think the country is
politically next year i'm gonna ask you
to
jump into my business here oh it's so
hard to predict i
look i i followed the polls i was
thinking biden's gonna win
until i went to my dry cleaner the other
day i i live in los
angeles and the guy sort of leaned in
i've been a lifelong democrat
and he leaned in and goes but i'm voting
for trump i think there's a lot more of
that than we know so it's tough to call
i'm gonna stick with biden on this i'm
hoping i'm wrong
well go check out birch gold right now
philip patrick precious metal specialist
for birch gold group really appreciate
the time thank you
alrighty so we are now six days out from
the election got two additional hours of
content coming up for you later today
go check us out this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nico geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses
are life family faith
those are fundamental and that's what
this show is about i hope you'll
give it a listen